well first things first welcome back
thank you it's good to see your face
again thank you so much it feels really
good to be back
you know you were retired after the
seventh installment so
what was that call like to come back it
happened
in steps and it happened very
organically and i think i owe it all to
vin because
ben would do certain things like he was
like you know show up at this commercial
that justin's shooting and
and i was like that's kind of weird but
okay like
because my brother always has a bigger
plan yeah and um
he makes stuff happen so i i definitely
owe it all to ben
i see you know what he did have a master
plan yeah he knew what the heck he was
he did
was it an easy yes for you though oh my
gosh yes
yes it never feels weird to come back it
always felt weird to not be a part of
my family and so it felt really really
good and i'd love to
and i know you you were probably still
seeing even if you weren't in you know
eight and
um still seen the movies and how they
still
keep paul's memory very much alive it's
very much alive in the fast universe
yes absolutely brian's definitely alive
in the fast universe and i think it's a
wonderful way to
to still honor paul and to keep his
memory alive
your favorite memory when you guys were
shooting you know through the franchise
throughout the whole franchise my
favorite movie was in fast five
where we were jumping in the favelas of
brazil and i was so nervous
because one day i had this harness like
waiting for me and i was like what is
this for
and um we have to do this massive jump
let's go
and paul was just like i got you like
and there was no way to like not feel
safe and comfortable with paul and i
think that's the energy that everyone
felt
so yeah he made me feel very safe maybe
this is the end
but we're gonna go out together no i'd
ride to the death with you when you
think about that
and the fact that we haven't even seen
this new movie here in the u.s and it's
already making hundreds of millions of
dollars overseas
the energy that the fans have put into
this franchise the money that has come
into this franchise
and you're a part of this history-making
franchise what does that mean to you
it's really really cool i was so happy
to see
that people were coming out of their
houses going back into the movies
seeing it collectively because i think
that's the way to see this movie you
can't see it any other way
and and i don't know there's something
about this one especially that has
really really good energy because i feel
like we're all collectively coming out
of this pandemic
and it's it's just kind of a celebration
and a way to get back into the theaters
because i know for a while everyone was
like no people can watch movies at home
and
absolutely not not this one this is a
film that you have to watch in theaters
and
we have to save cinema you know and keep
that alive because that's the way movies
should be seen
it's funny and this is this is no bs um
i
this screening this movie was my first
time back in the theater
my first time seeing a movie on the big
screen in so long and i
dropped a tear when it started i got
really emotional i didn't think
i loved the movie so much but i didn't
think it was going to feel like that you
know i had a real emotional moment
like because it's like a step towards
normalcy
you know and it's i think it's kind of
beautiful that all the stuff we took for
granted
now we're like oh wow i relish that and
i'm not going to stop relishing it it's
really cool
saturday night at the movies going on a
date night having popcorn
everything with my loved ones all of
those things let's get to work
please tell me that's not a pontiac
fiero strapped to a rocket engine
impressive i know no
no that's that's not impressive you know
this saga i know
you guys can't help but to like think
about how it's changed your
life your career your family we're
celebrating 20 years this year
how has it changed the trajectory
trajectory of your career
wow i mean it has fast and furious
allowed me to build a house um
fast and furious enabled me to stay at
school
when i was working when i was studying
at yale it
it made me feel safe staying there and
knowing that i would have a career
once i got out and it's also given me a
whole other family you know vin is my
brother
and michelle's my sister and i adore
justin
and it's just become like a home away
from home so i feel very fortunate
and in this film the stakes are even
higher because dom is a dad
yeah in this film how are the steaks
raised for you that first time you
became a mama
wow you know what acting became a lot
easier really because
yeah because in a way everything becomes
so much more raw
and i understood like mia's visceral
reaction to her kids being in danger
i think before then i was just faking it
and now it's just
i also think as a mom you're stressed
out so often that like
all of your emotions are like a hair
trigger away so
i just love acting now because it's such
a wonderful
uh way of of sort of it's very cathartic
for me let's just say
one of the things i also loved about
this movie was that i felt like
it was kind of a full circle moment
because you had also those scenes of
racing
through east l.a kind of the simplistic
like it was in the first movie what we
loved about that
i felt like it was a coming home of
source yeah you know
absolutely i think justin did such an
awesome job interweaving
all that's why he's the perfect director
for this franchise is that he
he honors the past fast and furious
and also you know i i loved like the
depiction of our dad
and and that history and the way those
scenes were shot like
everything became so clear to me and i
think the fans are going to love that as
well
yeah i like the back story i like
peeling back the layers scene all of
that it was really really cool to see
that
but here's my fan thing because you know
fans always have a theory
about what's happening so i feel like
that the end of this did set up the next
two movies for me and i think
because people like well how are they
going to top homeboys in space how are
they going to top the big old magnets
yes i'm like they're not they're going
to bring it all
back to the beginning and give us why we
fell in love with this franchise
in the beginning just simplistic racing
just do
that's so funny i thought i thought i
thought they would maybe do that with
this one
i think what they should do is they
should do that with the spin-offs
you know they should like if they do an
all-girl version which they've discussed
but who knows
i heard about that i think if they do
that we should pare it down and
and like make it really simple so you
michelle
maybe natalie in a big way charlize
helen mirren but like you don't need as
much
as many bells and whistles so that way
there's like a little less at stake i
think i think it'd be fun to like pare
it down do you have a storyline
in mind already for what you would want
to see that spin off
i don't might i i tip my hat off to the
writers of these franchises because i
think it's so
difficult to come up with innovative new
story lines but i do think
i think it'd be a really fun dynamic to
see us all together yeah
listen i have ideas going in my head so
so
i really want to see that because i mean
you all have
always painted the picture of very
strong fully realized
complex women in this franchise too and
i think that a standalone
you know telling their stories you know
really really you deserve it
thank you it's gonna happen watch it